[Musique]
Michel m'a fait de lit est-ce que la
France est un pays révolutionnaire ou un
pays conservateur
peut-être ni le ni l'autre enfin
en écoutant votre question je pensais à
ce que disait Joseph demestre à la fois
réactionnaire et pas et pas
conservateurs et en même temps vous
aurons autant avoir des soubresauts
indéniables et l'histoire de France
c'est quand même écrite dans le sang
beaucoup non ben disons que
régulièrement arrive des des
soulèvements de cet ordre je vais passer
un peu place de la Bastille et je me
souvenais que dans le fond un jour avant
le 14 juillet il y avait rien et puis
d'un coup cet espèce de soulèvement et
sur la place elle-même ces datlas 1830
1848 1871 vous voyez qui chaque fois
marque c'est ses soubresauts et en même
temps je dirais ce que je viens de dire
en citant je vous abdomestre quelque
chose qui fait qui a le
aussi et le sens des traditions voilà
et est-ce que la nation elle est
aujourd'hui si vous voulez aussi unique
elle n'a pu l'être par le passé
en même temps soyons clairs quand même
avant d'être unique comme cela il y a
des apports divers qui sont faits et
c'est là que se constitue la nation le
monde nation dit est intéressant en
latinataire et naître naître en un lieu
alors au bout d'un moment quand on est
le on est né dans ce lieu là ben ça crée
une espèce d'unité ou une unicité en
lien
indissoluble c'est ça la nation et vous
la faites remonter à quelle période cela
fait remonter à ce qui était Philippe
Auguste par exemple
un des premiers à rassembler justement
ce qui était des Baronnies épars d'une
certaine manière il faut pas l'oublier
et puis par après c'est repris par
Saint-Louis pour ne pas le nommer etc et
on voit se constituer un peu cette cette
nation dans le sens que je viens
d'indiquer une espèce de mosaïque qui se
structure à partir dans le fond
d'éléments très divers mais ce qui est
intéressant dans ce que vous venez de
dire c'est que dans l'imagerie populaire
et remonte à Vercingétorix pour vous non
c'est postérieur à ça oui moi je dis
Philippe Auguste c'est ce que disent les
historiens
on le fait que à partir de ce moment-là
il y a une organisation qui se fait et
une dans le sens simple du terme une
gestion ce qu'est à l'origine
essentiellement par là mais le politique
et l'État précède la nation l'État et ce
qui va rassembler les morceaux
familière alors tout à l'heure vous
disiez il y a souvent des soulèvements
et vous avez écrit un livre d'ailleurs
qui s'appelle l'ère des soulèvements
est-ce que c'est soulèvement vous les
pressentez plus fréquents aujourd'hui
que par le passé dans notre pays alors
que ça fait quand même pas mal de temps
que il s'est pas passé grand chose de ce
le pays certes et peut-être un volcan
mais il y a pas eu de manifestation
extérieure en dehors de Mai 68 des
gilets jaunes et des choses comme ça je
suis un vieux universitaire j'ai plus de
m'excuser puis je vous le dirai répondre
à latin Queen novice
sur le soleil et on voit régulièrement
revenir de ces formes de ce soulèvement
il faut pas mais moi j'essaie de le voir
sur la longue durée en bref chaque fin
d'époque entraîne cela moi je rappelle
que le mot époque en grec signifie
parenthèse ça s'ouvre une parenthèse se
ferme pour moi est en train de se fermer
la parenthèse moderne les cordes
modernes voilà et que du coup ben quand
quelque chose de cet ordre a lieu quand
tu ne parenthèse se ferme quand
une autre époque va s'ouvrir il y a
entre ces deux époques là encore si on
fait des distinctions un peu sémantiques
des périodes durent quelques décennies
entre des époques les époques durent
quatre siècles les périodes dure
quelques décennies et là il y a des
grouillements des et on est dans cette
période là qui est en jeu il y a une
période fait défervescence alors qui
sont très divers c'est pas la révolution
dans le sens encore une fois tel que les
staliniens nous l'ont imposé
c'est-à-dire une avant-garde qui impose
un peuple quel est le sens de la société
à venir non c'est pas ça c'est des je
viens de dire le mot grouillement
fourmillement alors ce que vous avez
souligné il y a un instant les gilet
jaune avant les bonnets rouges les
convois de la liberté les multiples
rassemblements juvénients autour des
rêves parties un peu partout alors pour
moi c'est un peu c'est voilà ce que
j'appelle l'air des soulèvements
c'est-à-dire dans cette période instable
où on pressant les valeurs qui sont en
train de s'achever les grandes valeurs
modernes c'est à dire l'individualisme
le rationalisme le progressisme c'est
fini ça ça c'est terminé ça oui je le
pense c'est ce que enfin moi pour ma
part c'est ce que j'essaie d'analyser ça
va être remplacé par quoi difficile à
dire difficile d'être prophète mais en
tout cas au lieu d'être d'avoir
l'individualisme cartésien qui a le
pivot en quelque sorte des institutions
modernes le Michel Foucault le montre
bien commencer la mort ses institutions
sociales au 19e siècle c'est plus le jeu
c'est le loup qui va prévaloir j'écris
un livre il y a quelques-uns qui
s'appelle le temps des tribus le temps
des tribus on va reparler des trucs et
donc pour moi c'est le loup
c'est plus le jeu ça va je dirais à
l'encontre de tout ce qu'on entend ce
qu'on raconte en disant que on est dans
une société qui est toujours davantage
individualiste ça c'est une sotise
journalistique je vous prie de maness
blues en prie et au contraire au
contraire on entend on entend cette
phrase que venait de dire comme étant
une incantation compte tenu de
l'individualisme contemporain il suffit
de sortir dans la rue pour voir que nos
jeunes sont toujours en relation avec
les autres téléphones ou téléphone
portable
c'est le nous qui prévaut pour le
meilleur et pour le pire ce qui est en
gestation il y a pas beaucoup de pires
mais pour moi c'est le nom qui prévaut
alors que le discours officiel les
élites politiques
un journaliste expert de tout genre vont
dire il y a de l'individualisme non très
non un peu dans la rue pour se rendre
compte que ceux qui est en jeu c'est la
tribus c'est un effet quelque chose qui
c'est la communauté alors on a peur de
savoir dire aux communautarisme c'est
fréquent oui stigmatisation comme de la
même manière qu'on a tellement peur de
du peuple qu'on dit populisme
non alors pour moi c'est le nous qui est
en gestation actuellement ce que
j'appelle un idéal communautaire en
gestation et juste comment c'est plus le
rationnel le rationalisme surinez qui
était une des dominante voilà c'est pour
moi l'émotionnel sous ces diverses
modulations et puis c'est plus le
progressisme on parle tout le temps le
progrès machin chose non c'est vivre au
présent comme le Carpediem comme
cueillir aujourd'hui les roses de la vie
comme ça etc
un peu c'est un peu cela qui est en
instant dans le glissement qui est en
train de s'opérer est-ce que Michel m'a
fait joli ce que vous venez de décrire
qui est beau vraiment c'est une
singularité française ou c'est quelque
chose que vous retrouvez dans on va dire
dans la sphère occidentale
non pour moi c'est une réalité qui est
mondiale qui est mondiale le les
premières valeurs que j'ai indiqué ont
été élaborées dans le laboratoire de la
modernité que fut l'Europe et la France
en particulier
la philosophie
siècle les grands systèmes sociaux du
19e et la France jouait là un rôle
indéniable pour moi actuellement le
laboratoire de ce que certains appellent
la postmodernité je suis de cela et bien
c'est ailleurs peut-être le Brésil c'est
peut-être la Corée c'est à dire là où
c'est eux qui sont pas dans la sphère
occidentale justement non non ils sont
pas forcément essayer de
nous rayon mythique c'est pas un Orient
pour moi vous voyez je pense pas
uniquement à l'oreillant
géographiquement
non je dis un Orient mythique je fais
exprès de dire Brésil
il se trouve des pays où je vais très
souvent ou j'ai beaucoup d'anciens
étudiants qui montrent
analyse effectivement ce que je viens
d'indiquer c'est-à-dire cet idéal
communautaire en gestation qui nous est
assez étrangers soyons clairs le cogito
ergo Soum cartésien et ceux qui nous a
formés fortement alors vous êtes en
train de nous dire en fait que
l'universalisme dont la France voulait
porteuse et remise en question
actuellement oui je pense que
l'universalisme je veux dire c'est cette
valeur qui a été imposée par la force
des baïonnettes des soldats dans les
marchands avec la Bible démissionnaires
jusqu'à la fin du 19e siècle moi je
donne deux dates pour entre attentif à
cela 1865 quand l'empereur du Japon fait
venir les juristes Lyonnais pour faire
la Constitution mejj
1888 quand le Brésil met sur ses
bannières le mot d'ordre d'Auguste Comte
ordre et Progrès ça c'est universalisme
jusque ces dates la fin du 19e ben là
voilà il y a un changement qui est en
train de s'opérer il y a disons une
contamination une orientalisation du
monde a bien les gars et nous serons
pris dans cette orientalisation du monde
vous voulez dire par là que la France va
perdre ses singularités aussi culturelle
et civilisationnel j'ai peur de le dire
moi j'aime tellement la France que je
regrette de dire ce que je dis à bien
des égards mais c'est à nous de savoir
dans le fond accompagné la transmutation
qui est en jeu actuellement une vraie
transmutation hypocale nous avons peur
en France dans le milieu intellectuel en
particulier mais pas que de parler du
mot que j'ai employé poste modernité
en oubliant que le mot modernité dont on
se que l'on emploie attire la Ringo a
été employée en 1848 par Charles
Baudelaire avant on disait poche
médiévalidité voilà bon donc c'est assez
tardif le mot modernité etc et pour moi
c'est un peu quelque chose qui est en
jeu actuellement on est en train de
quitter la modernité et on de dire post
modernité non c'est à nous de savoir
accompagner ce processus et à nous de
redonner à la France et à ceux qui
étaient la théorie française
la génération avant la mienne celle de
baudrillage de lyota de Foucault etc
rayonner de Parlement et bien tout
simplement peut-être à n'oublions les
pontifs d'une surprise de m'excuser de
cette espèce de de
marxisme attardé
française c'est quoi ce marxiste matinée
et bien encore une fois cet espèce de
valorisation à outrance du progrès le
progressisme
l'individualisme le fait que c'est une
avant-garde qui va donner la conscience
que le peuple doit avoir de lui-même
alors que si on est attentif à ceux qui
moi mes chers cette sagesse populaire et
bien là peut-être qu'on sera justement
accompagné ce que j'appelais cet idéal
communauté alors vous allez voir vous
parler du rayonnement du rôle que la
France a joué à l'étranger il y en a un
qui qui avait une haute idée de tout
cela c'est Charles de Gaulle et on va
l'écouter je me fais en effet de la
France une certaine idée
je veux dire par là qu'à mon sens elle
est quelque chose
de très grand de très particulier
c'est du reste je le pense ressenti par
le monde entier
c'est vrai la France est une chose
à mes yeux
très considérable très valable et
elle doit avoir dans le monde quel qu'il
soit tout époque naturellement d'après
les circonstances elle doit avoir un
rôle à elle
il faut que la France joue son rôle
c'est exact et pour qu'elle joue son
rôle il faut qu'elle soit la France
les Français les Français ceux qui font
la France
c'est eux qui en sont responsables la
France est plus que les français du
moment
la France vient de loin
beaucoup de choses sont dites avec
l'enfance goliène évidemment
il parle du rôle que la France a joué
dans le monde et elle décline cette
parole
c'est très émouvant d'entendre ce qu'on
vient d'entendre et je pense est une
belle idée que de mettre l'argent sur
l'idée bien sûr ce côté dans le sens du
terme spirituel et le propre d'un effet
de la tradition française et de longue
date alors le décline je vous ai dit oui
pour partir
je vais vous le dire un peu simplement
tenez moi je suis encore invité et
j'étais jusqu'à deux trois ans invité à
Shanghai pour le grand coloc culturel
qui se fait j'étais le seul Français ah
oui 10 ans avant ben au contraire il y
avait les noms que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure de l'OZ Baudrillard Foucault etc
etc donc là il y a une espèce oui de
décadence pour une raison précise c'est
que à bien des égards pour ceux que je
connais moi dans le milieu intellectuel
dans des domaines qui me sont propres
c'est-à-dire soit la philosophie soit la
sociologie et de gérable et bien il n'y
a pas eu de renouvellement dans la
génération au pouvoir
par contre ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'il y a une génération qui arrive il
n'y a pas un jour où je reçois tel ou
tel jeune étudiant qui vient me voir et
là les générations en jeu actuellement
c'est générations de jeunes eux sont
porteur d'un bel avenir et alors vous
avez ce mot-là de tribu est-ce que la
France c'est une tribu
ou ce sont des tribus plutôt des tribus
plutôt des tripes c'est quoi une tribu
d'ailleurs
quand j'ai écrit sans rentrer oh non
j'écris Alix le temps des tribus c'était
un peu une provocation à l'époque pour
rendre attentif au fait qu'on ne pouvait
plus rester sur cette vieille idée du
19e la République une et indivisible
voilà ça c'est une c'est inscrit dans la
Constitution je le sais je le sais mais
il ne reste pas moins qu'à bien des
égards c'est en train de tomber
en même temps revenant à cette belle
idée de la race publique la chose
publique peut être la conjonction j'ai
dit mosaïque d'éléments divers pour moi
c'est un peu cela qui est en jeu donc du
coup oui à qu'on le veuille ou non pour
le meilleur et pour le pire j'insiste
encore là dessus des tribus des
communautés plutôt que de rester sur ce
schéma encore une fois de la République
une indivisible qui va gommer les
spécificités les particularités voir
comment on peut agréger intégrer moi je
suis un petit village des Cévennes où il
y a eu beaucoup mon grand-père était
italien qui est je vais travailler dans
le CV il y avait des Espagnols il y
avait des checks il y avait des Polonais
et on voit bien comment il fallait
perdre la langue d'origine pour rentrer
dans ce qu'était encore une c'était
l'intégration l'assimilation la
simulation que l'assimilation mais ne
parlons pas de ces langues d'origine moi
je vois mes grands-parents c'est venol
parler le patois loup patoises là aussi
c'est pas toi a disparu au nom du
rouleau compresseur en quelque sorte de
ce que devait être la langue nationale
alors on peut imaginer qu'il puisse y
avoir actuellement et c'est mon
hypothèse moi une espèce de conjonction
de ces diversités encore une fois
l'Occitanie l'Alsace la nation bretonne
la nation corse et tout à l'avenant pour
tout pourquoi nous pourrions-nous pas
penser cet espèce de conjonction ce
qu'on appelle
permissivement encore de le dire en
latin une coïncidence
coïncidence des choses opposées qui
peuvent aboutir à cette respounica ouais
il y a la France et la France et la
France cela dit quand on regarde un
petit peu notamment quand il s'est passé
quand il y a des réformes en France
quand on parle du droit à la
différenciation d'une région par rapport
à une autre et puis qu'on regarde notre
devise Liberté Égalité Fraternité on
s'aperçoit qu'à chaque fois et on l'a vu
d'ailleurs beaucoup pendant les
confinements à l'occasion du coronavirus
l'égalité prime surtout tout le reste
dans notre pays c'est à dire que quand
il était question de de faire un
confinement à Marseille qui n'existait
pas ailleurs les marseillais étaient
révoltés en disant au nom de l'égalité
on nous sacrifie l'égalité est plus
importante que la liberté en France non
moi je crois que c'est l'un et l'autre
c'est des mots désuet qui ne veulent
plus rien dire
notre devise non plus
on repose la question on le voit sur le
fronton bien évidemment et c'est on a
été nourri et bellement par cela voilà
non moi je on a commencé en parlant de
de ce qui est réactionnaire
moi je crois qu'il y a le retour un peu
de la hiérarchie plutôt que de l'égalité
ah et que l'idée de la hiérarchie c'est
que le fait que d'une certaine manière
il y a des juxtaposition de choses
différentes
il y a besoin d'autorité actuellement en
France la autorita c'est ce qui fait
croître c'est ça au l'auteur c'est celui
qui croit que vos idées etc et donc
plutôt que de ce gamberger de ce de
continuer à parler de cette égalité voir
que de fait de fait il y a au contraire
un souci de la hiérarchie c'est-à-dire
des des différences que l'on a en
fonction de ses qualités personnelles où
je peux être le chef a tel moment et pas
à tel autre etc et c'est à dire que on
serait favorable à une démocratie
autoritaire
je vous prie de m'excuser moi je crois
que l'idéal démocratique est finie
maintenant le processus d'abstention les
non inscrites sur les listes électorales
traduisent bien que ce bel idéal
démocratique a fait son temps voilà et
c'est pour ça que je parle moi d'un
idéal communautaire en gestation
qu'est-ce que c'est que l'idéal
d'hémorique cette grande dame de la
pensée qui en a Arendt le dit j'ai une
représentation philosophique c'est à
dire encore plus d'idées j'arrive à vous
convaincre vous me donnez votre voix
représentation politique où est-ce que
actuellement cette représentation
philosophique
l'abstention est un phénomène important
la vue ce qu'on ne dit pas les non
inscrits sur les listes électorales qui
représentent dit-on entre 10 et 15%
d'une population en état de voter alors
si on additionne ce que je viens de dire
une fois qu'on a fait le partage un élu
on peut se gamberger on peut les
célébrer il ne représente que 10 à 12%
d'une population c'est plus dans la
représentation voilà pourquoi je dis ce
n'est plus l'idéal démocratique qui est
qui est même si on galère de cette
idéale démocratique voilà et vous avez
une autre expression alors moi je dis
quoi alors
ce que je vous ai dit la démocratie
participative oui peut-être la
moi j'ai eu pour mettre Julien Franck
était un grand sociologue du politique
et qui rappelait dans le fond que dans
la cité antique on ne pouvait gérer la
cité commune que si on savait gérer sa
maison ouais l'idée en fait bien sûr
montrer que je suis allé être incarné il
fallait pas être des incarné alors
actuellement c'est idéal démocratique
c'est une caste qui dans le fond était
désincarné on le voit de diverses
manières on a montré ici dans le débat
là-dessus et donc revenir encore une
fois
au politique la police antique la cité
dans le fond la commune on n'a pas de
mots en français c'est l'école de Palo
Alto qui en Californie qui dit proximi
vous voyez moi j'ai dit c'est le lieu
félien c'est-à-dire que ça en fonction
du lieu qui a du lien social voilà ce
qu'est le politique il faudrait revenir
à cette incarnation et que c'est un peu
cela qui et ce que j'appelle moi l'idéal
communautaire en gestation alors bien
sûr que c'est aussi la démocratie si on
revient à la démocratie dans le centre
du pouvoir du peuple en son sens
étymologique mais actuellement tout ce
qui se proclame démocrate sont peu démo
files il n'aime pas le peuple du tout ce
que vous décrivez là c'est plutôt une
notion de gauche ou une notion de droite
on voit la déperdition de la gauche et
la droite
non ma position je sais que c'est
toujours un peu embêtant de dire ce que
je dis elle le renvoie davantage à la au
peuple ou simplement faut pas avoir peur
du peuple
saint Thomas d'Aquin qui est un de mes
expirateurs
toute l'autorité vient du peuple
[Musique]
donc voilà donc c'est pas quelque chose
qui est ce partage qui était celui de la
droite et de la gauche et on a vu
comment au dernières élections c'est
parti représentant et la gauche et la
droite sont
non c'est plutôt revenir encore une fois
à cette réalité populaire voilà
Michel m'a fait désolé je voudrais vous
demander de vous prêter un petit jeu
quelle questionnaire de Proust si la
France et bien si la France était un
paysage de quelle sera-t-il pour vous ah
bon moi le paysage que j'aime c'est le
paysage de mon enfance
c'est là où je suis né je rappelle la
formule on est de son enfance comme d'un
pays et donc oui c'est ce paysage ou
d'ailleurs je garde mes racines et je
considère que ce retour racine c'est ça
la tradition étant élément qui va jouer
un rôle de plus en plus important la
plante humaine tout d'un coup se
souvient que comme toute plante elle a
besoin de racines pour croître voilà
pourquoi moi c'est mon paysage est-ce
que c'est pas alors est-ce que ça se
résume pas tout ça à un mot qui est pas
très populaire mais qui s'appelle la
réaction tout simplement non mais le mot
réaction ne me fait pas peur moi
je considère que tout de suite quand on
dit révisionnaire on s'entend mais
réactionnaires non moi je le revendique
simplement dans le sens encore une fois
de rendre attentif à l'importance de la
tradition d'art et ce qui a été donné on
le transporte voilà alors si c'était une
toile
peinture bon j'ai pensé à BRUGEL c'est
un peu étonnant parce que dans le fond
c'est pas c'est pas on va le voir
peut-être un peintre français il est
voilà voilà mais traduit bien un peu ce
côté maintenant on utilise ce mot un peu
chier ce côté festif qui pour moi est
une tradition française très française
je rappelle que dans beaucoup de nos
villages il y a le four banal et le four
banal à l'encontre on dit banal ça veut
rien dire non le four banal c'était le
jour où le Seigneur rétrocédé le four à
la communauté c'était la fête du pain
commun voilà pour moi en quel sens je
dirais que pour le dire d'une manière
très simple tout est bon pour faire la
fête est expression populaire qui est
pas fou à mon sens ce qui est en jeu
voilà dans le dans cette dans cette
peinture là quoi un écrivain
bon moi c'est Châteaubriand ouais
château brillant mais je sais pas
pourquoi son anti
napoléonisme ou non c'est
Maroli l'enchanteur donc d'une certaine
manière on sait que ce qui raconte pour
participer faux mais c'est très beau
voilà et il y a deux choses moi je les
relis régulièrement et les mémoire
pardon les mémoires d'autres tombent il
y a quelques jours je lisais j'avais mon
mon ma Playa dans main de mémoires de
temps mais mon voisin se pend sur moi il
me dit ah vous lisez je le relie aussi
ah oui le métro c'est un animal etc non
ben c'est quand même Saint-Malo c'est
quand même combo c'est à dire vous voyez
il est il est un mot qu'il emploie et
qui m'a toujours fait rêver matrie pas
simplement la patrie matrimerie ce lieu
le vent les orages les machins les
choses qui dans le fond lui rappelle ce
qui est sa racine ça c'est à partir de
quoi il peut croître voilà pourquoi ça
te brillant me
et alors un personnage historique alors
bon pour moi c'est Saint-Louis
intellectuelle en disant la somme de
Jacques Le Goff Saint Louis un livre 20
et montrant lui Saint-Louis le
petit-fils de Philippe Auguste
c'est-à-dire celui qui va structurer
l'État le chêne de Vincennes où il va
rendre la justice c'est-à-dire c'est ce
côté Proximus que là encore une fois
c'est à dire très attaché au peuple a
bien des égards et que quand il rend la
justice tout le monde peut accéder au
roi et puis n'oublions pas c'est à ce
moment-là que commence dans la tradition
catholique la confession auriculaire
et c'est Robert de Sorbon qui est son
confesseur et sorbant c'est la Sorbonne
évidemment il était très lié aux
intellectuels il y a une petite anecdote
amusante il reçoit saint Thomas d'Aquin
un dîner par exemple on sait pas si
c'est les gens ou non mais enfin
s'adresse pas moins que saint Thomas qui
était ce gros monsieur un peu taciturne
un moment donné s'écrit pendant le dîner
j'ai trouvé voilà et c'est ce contact là
avec le roi qui est important je
rappelle là la formule
dans le fond
mon arc illettré étonna ne couronné
[Rires]
était justement les traits et c'est le
seul de nos rois qui est sanctifié ce
qui n'est pas négligeable merci Michel
m'a fait joli merci bien
[Musique]